freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich bin heute hier mit
niemand geringerem als eric der mich
seit einem jahr begleitet auf meinem weg
unsere leser eric hat jedes restaurant
mit mir probiert er kriegt immer was zu
essen sondern die freiheit hat aber er
kann auch immer gesagt du musst mal zu
mir kommen dass wir dann muss man zu mir
kommen das probieren das natürlich zu
jeder hat ja so seine lieblings spots
man will seinen lieblingsplatz auch
immer so die haben zeigen du hast sie
noch nicht gesehen und gewisse allen
zeigen ich kenne es auch wir tun es auch
aber heute technics lieblingsplatz ab
wir sind auf ersten spot angekommen
angespannte kassenlage allererstes form
aus hier ist gilt weg hinein also vom
aussehen her sage ich ehrlich
gefühlschaos aber sogar schmecken und
ich war dabei als er mit freunden aus
bonn gesagt wo wir hingehen und all mein
tor sehr gut dass wir dahin geht also
wird schon passen ich bin gespannt wie
wir machen es so du sagst einfach zu
bestellen würde sich da erst mal hier
auf jeden fall stolz das schließt
dahinten das
ist quasi kleine portionen zum teil es
ist allein und dann sagen wir mehrere
orte die ich bei dir benannt so viel
zugenommen immer so nach feierabend
hierher vielen dank dass ich mir direkt
gedacht haben beim reinkommen mit jedem
mal wo man tiefer in den laden geht der
kasse diesmal kommt einzig okay diese
fleisch hieß es wäre das hier drin auch
höchst richtig hübsch für seinen imbiss
und wenn dann das essen auf dem tisch
steht mir läuft schon das wasser im mund
zusammen ich habe noch nichts gegessen
beste voraussetzungen ich mag das auch
schaffen so
aus wie
große erstmal
danke das
was ich immer daran liebe es so wiesen
schaum sind zu essen schmeckt möglich
warschau weg sondern note schauen oben
ist auch das geheimnis um so reddig für
heute zwischen elga mir ist immer so ein
kleines spaß battle zwischen bonn und
köln bonn und ich schwöre natürlich auch
köln aber eric wenn wir heute
hat mehr auswahl nicht so bonn hat auch
schöne spots viel weniger fans kurz aber
sehr sehr schönes los und ich freue mich
wirklich die aufzuzeigen und ich bin
ernst gespannt auf deine meinung mit
gern nehmen wir einen davon reden die
knoblauchsoße rein erstmal ein bisschen
zitrone und ganze wird es mal rein
[Musik]
ich finde aber seht ihr auch ein paar
vor der kamera wie immer ein grund hat
man das war so seitdem ich diesen sport
entdeckt haben ich muss doch einmal die
wir auch hier hingekommen dann sollen
neben diesen kräuteröl was hast du
eigentlich viel geschmack und das
fleisch ultra saftig was auch so ganz
anders irgendwie ganz anders also sowohl
würde aber weiß warum warum ich glaube
dass hens im fleische scott also
hähnchen komplett schenkel fleisch gilt
dieses schöne siege fleisch was einfach
das kann eigentlich gar nicht trocken
werden fast schon wirklich gute
benchmark dass es nicht ich weiß gar
nicht was an kraft ist was ich aber
fühle das schon so ein bisschen
turbulent beschleunigen jetzt kommt zu
dieser schlug einer noch gefährlich ich
auf meinen hungrigen leben wagen hier
das ist das größte was mache ich dann so
eine 11
was mich nur frage wie willst du mir
noch weiter gut aus zeigen ich bin so
sein dass ich irgendetwas kleines
vielleicht das was ein pärchen das süß
ab zur nächsten sportback und
fußball-meister du willst aus kleines
süßes also hier richtig zur besten
eisdiele in deutschland 2015 ins eisler
wollen bonn ein stimmungsvoller besser
als in deutschland ist ein flex von
tripadvisor sind gerade von da wo wir
immer unsere bewertungen ziehen also ich
hab euch noch nie als praline gegessen
hast du uns erzählen sehr kranke sommer
weight
knallt und tragen diese schokolade habe
so mega knusprig innen drin so sahnige
size wieso heißt kontext und dann können
wir auch als verlieren ich habe doch das
schmeckt aber wieso lehrer holte
alexandre so lähmungen ja zu eins kann
man nicht so wahnsinnig viel sagen also
außer becker ist aber blutorangen der
bhc frauen und ich finde ein gutes
zeichnet aus dass es auch cremig ist
nicht so schlecht des eises sehr wässrig
sehr kristalle kluft ist
das beste ein sieg macht sich klein aber
dass das hört als gerne bei jeder reise
begeben ist ebenso wie wahnsinnig süß
hier das text sowie die hier so einfach
komplett auf keks wave sind für die
löffelten sogar die luft ist draussen
nichtsdestotrotz sehr sehr lecker meist
erfrischung zwischendurch und so für uns
für heute für diesen schönen sonnigen
tag daran hat zwischen ein bisschen
kicken das von lakers perfekt aber ich
bin gerade so richtig am mittag steve
myers bisher sehr jetzt sagen wir sehen
uns beim nächsten speed noch
22 punkte habe ich noch für dich erstmal
irgendwie bisschen spazieren gehen oder
so weil das fürchtet alter das frühstück
sage ich schon was feines stück aber
sind die express war hart gegen kanada
ich bin gespannt was sagen wir sind
heute
hast du dir ja auf jeden fall abgehakt
aber die brauchen wir auch eric hat
schon angeteasert das kein normaler pc
welt hinein wir sind bei cala d'or in
der bonner innenstadt es ist eine pizza
die du glaub ich noch nicht so gegessen
hast es ist eine eine ehren lose pfizer
aber sie gehört zu den top box das ist
so eine pizza isst oder eigentlich kommt
zusammen vier nachziehen so lange wir
auch und dann trotzdem
[Musik]
gespannt erzählt dass das sehr lecker
sein soll wir euch
[Musik]
und das wichtigste ich habe sie gerade
schon gezeigt und jetzt diesen saucen
hier muss sich vorstellen dass der
zweite laden ist der neue laden davon im
ersten laden war das immerhin uns in so
einer bierflasche und st die wird jetzt
in ordentlicher menge oder wir haben
heute schon so
das ist ganz wichtig hält sein team
knoblauch wird das ist es jetzt also ich
bin ganz ehrlich ganz offen zugeben dass
sie muss jetzt krank schmecken weil das
ist halt so was sieht man sieht ja ein
cooles konzept und dann liegen auch
riesige säcke doppelnull mehr aber so
vorgebacken noch schnell was draußen ab
gebacken ist so dass jetzt hat der
geschmack überzeugen ja auf jeden fall
das ist halt auch nichts was jetzt fans
also ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass die
qualität scheiße ist aber dass jetzt
nicht so mit liebe gebacken so weiß ich
meine das geht schnell so und das muss
auch wirklich schnell gehen weil wie
gesagt wir kommen uns um drei uhr nachts
sind dann stehen die 100 leute die
wollen alle
dass unsere lange reden dann von unten
stimmen wurden die 12 diese auch so
richtig den alkohol presse probieren wir
wurden probleme
[Musik]
das macht mehr sinn als gedacht von asse
aufgezeigt schön knusprig aus oder
auch der boden auch wie sie steht das
haben sie tatsächlich besser gemacht als
sonst sagt ganze liste wie können wir
sie scheiße ist die gar nicht nein nein
ich weiß jetzt schon die super lecker es
ist nicht eine pizza wie du sie die
letzten zwei jahre dir gegönnt als wenn
du mal eine pizza lass mich ausholen
hätten wir das gezeigt nachdem wir nach
dem letzten spot und deiner lieblings
klar waren wir zwei drei vier fünf
stunden verkosten und genießen
kraft ja es ist halt so kann ich bin so
hat zu 100 prozent seine
daseinsberechtigung an so einem faulen
sonntag wenn man gesoffen hat so weißt
du dass es so ein ding mit dem schickst
du dich aus dem leben aber du kannst
dich noch keiner aus dem leben schicken
würde ich jetzt hier gibt es ein auch
konsumieren nicht sagen obwohl waren in
köln also dass napolitan ist keine sache
gut das ist normalerweise klar mädchen
in ihlow mit stolz gezeigt aber warum
sollen wir noch mal zu den melodien
werden wir schon da waren also das ist
ja dasselbe deswegen es ist halt eine
andere liga als zum beispiel was mir
heute mittag ist die mainzer heute
mittag l vom 10 das ist so eine
siebeneinhalb das ist uns uns denkt es
und wenn es den richtigen zweck wie ist
das übelste aber wenn du so kommst und
die kasten sachen essen willst ja ist es
neben den anderen etwas weniger genau
gleich beim abendessen ich habe extra
einen tisch reserviert da weiß ich dass
ich dich wieder überzeugen werde ich
sage nur selbst gemachte pommes ein
salat der sehr unscheinbar aussieht aber
geschmack richtig überzeugen wird
hoffentlich und lammkoteletts vom grill
die sehen wir gleich eine person nein
aber es sieht interessanter mitreden und
zwar um dann gehen die leute es auch ist
ein schnuckeliges eckchen sagen wir sind
jetzt gefühlt gleich auch was jetzt was
später soll wir sind hier auf dem dorf
viel kleinerer stadtteil von kleineren
stadtteil so aber griechisches
restaurant exotisch ist gar nicht mal so
viel erfahrung habe ich mit griechischer
küche aber auch einmal kennt halt gyros
und so nahm man weiß aber vor allem auch
dass sie sehr sehr lecker sein kann
deshalb bin ich gespannt was du mir
zeigen wird aber ich würde auf jeden
fall seien wohl etwas mitzuteilen
hier sind wir hier wir sind auf santorin
griechische taverne
ich muss wirklich sagen es ist sehr
kritisch der das konzept der griechisch
gehalten krieg stahlkonzerns leicht
grieg wir sind schon so wäre könnte auf
den eurovisions zu begründen beim essen
ehrlich gesagt kann einmal was wir jetzt
essen werden was sind deine empfehlung
also ich bin hierher nicht zum ersten
mal die gibt es natürlich auch in büros
sitzen souvlaki jetzt muss er ganz
klassische griechische gerichte aber ich
liebe ihr die grillspezialitäten und vor
allen dingen die lammkoteletts
also würde ich auf jeden fall sagen wir
stellen einmal die lammkoteletts ja wir
müssen dafür noch eine kleine vorspeise
nehmen ok bestellt so wie du für dich
bestellen würde und ich nehme nur
jeweils eine gabel okay obwohl bekommst
minimum zitierte zucchini mit tzatziki
wahrscheinlich in der mitte hier ist das
gute und das gute essen
[Musik]
hmm
kimi ist ja so übungsleiter und das
außen ist so trotzdem so perfekt hier
ist das ganz normal mit aubergine ich
nehme ja so eine kleine muss man einfach
so ganz eintracht
kommt noch mal vater das ist eine
oberliga dies in noch weiter irgendwie
noch weiter und diese vom textur hier
gar nicht so wie aubergine cancer
aubergine hat häufig so einen leichten
schub ist so ein bisschen widerstand
beim ground diese richtung die mählich
unsere kinder und die ist einfach innen
drin einfach nur so eine luftige macht
das richtig du hast du fehler gemacht
weil du mir als allererstes city gezeigt
was es heißt so krass war bin gespannt
was du zu den lammkotelett sagt darauf
bin ich auch sehr gespannt weil ich weiß
dass du einen fleischkonsums service und
wenn du die abfahrt und dann sind die
glauben experten
danke alles bis jetzt war nur play plate
wenn ich das so sehe du hast ja auch so
wie du geredet hast mein spaß ist das
krasse und die kommen ja das sieht schon
sehr sehr saftig aus und muss ich sagen
deshalb werde ich so einen richtigen
klang so morris und was ja auch helfen
dass ihr das so hochgezogen haben checks
oder sind so sind so lang shops das ist
das große finale ja bitte packt ihr
direkt einen job in den zickereien 3 1
aber mit live nation problem ist dass
wir jetzt sogar vorfand noch mehr
englisch reden also wieso schafft
also
jetzt
in noch so leicht rosa
[Musik]
butter zahl richtig geiles grill aroma
man merkt auch die fleischpreise sehr
weist ein schöner durchwachsen alarm
geschmack lassen es richtig lecker und
jetzt alles
der knospe prima mit touchscreen also
dass er jetzt so einstufen sollten ja
die pommes mit dem hause gehen
die machen sich bock zu essen das sind
diese klassischen komposition skepsis
spaß machen sowieso doch dreifach
vierfach dotierten adresse eines
reporters aber diese kranken lamm gottes
stellen das so in den schatten für mich
die sind wirklich köstlich schmeckt
nicht nur pop von wörtern und der dafür
müssen wörter erfunden werden ja aber es
ist alles egal weil ich fühle dass er
kommt bekommt welches land kommen wegen
dem salat und es lohnt sich wegen eines
losen gegen den lange und es wird sich
wegen des project super schöner rahmen
zum essen geben kann dich also so man
hat das gefühl man hat so ein
authentisches restaurant und möchte nur
dafür lustig wir haben sicherlich schon
besseres essen gegessen aber
jeder hat das vielleicht auch bei sich
in der home tonnen so man hat einfach so
seines sports romanvorlagen hingeht wo
man sehr sehr gerne hingeht wo auch die
emotionale bindung so ein bisschen
vielleicht mitspielt und deswegen
hochschule auf 100% der spot davor mit
der pizza das ist so ein ding wo ihr
vielleicht schon 100 mal hingegangen
seit nachdem wir feiern ja ja und dann
checke ich auch dass so eine institution
für einen würze weise ja
nichtsdestotrotz ich bin so dankbar dass
du mir deine seele gezeigt hast auf
jeden fall sehr sehenswert sehr nice bis
gleich was soll ich sagen heute es gibt
auch ihren verein laden der mir ganz
lange nicht aus dem kopf bleiben wird
und das ist city express also notwehr
ist unnormal krass die anderen eben wie
gesagt haben alle ihre
daseinsberechtigung und die bombe direkt
am anfang dort sind die notizen direkt
via direkten standard gesetzt wir sind
übrigens gerade hier mitten im dreh seid
gespannt darauf und bist du nicht wieder